we also want to tell you this morning
about a Kansas City teenager fighting
for his life after being shot for
knocking on the wrong door the family of
16 year old Ralph yarl says he was
trying to pick up his younger brothers
when he made a mistake he mistook one
address for another
and someone shot police say the person
who shot this team has not been charged
at least not so far Lily Luciano has
more on this story
you should never ever have to worry that
your light will be taken one block
difference is what the family of 16 year
old Raphael say landed him in the
hospital Thursday with what's described
as life-threatening injuries yarl was
supposed to pick up his younger brothers
from a friend's house on 115th Terrace
in Kansas City but she says instead he
went to 115th Street where he rang the
bell and that's when police say a man
opened fire shooting him in the head
y'all's aunt said the man then shot him
again there is a thorough investigation
underway now there will be a thorough
review in the prosecutor's office we
will make sure we do all we can to be
fair to make sure that we're as
expeditious as possible the homeowner
who allegedly shot the teen was taken
into custody on a 24-hour hold and was
released police cited the need for
further investigation and for a formal
statement from the victim as some of the
reasons well the identity of the shooter
remains unknown many in the community
worry race may be a factor Kansas City's
police chief acknowledged that concern I
want everyone to want to know that I'm
listening
and I understand the concern that we are
receiving from the community
protesters gathered and demonstrated on
Sunday calling for justice including
yarl's father I have a message for the
prosecutor we want charges
that's what we want if he goes free the
next black kid that's gonna ring that
doorbell could get shot again
that was Luciano reporting you could see
how easily you could make the mistake
115th Street 115th Terrace but let's
talk about Ralph Laurel for just a
second he's described as a section
leader in the marching band one of the
top base clarinet players in Missouri
his friends and teachers describe him as
kind soul quiet friendly well
well-mannered willing to help no
criminal record his family says super
smart and a musical genius I mean thank
God he's still alive let's just start
with that thank you so much he's so
alive but there are still so many
questions you knock on the door they say
it wasn't threatening according to the
family and the attorneys he was just
knocking on the doors to pick up his
little brothers yeah based on what we
know now unless it's legal to shoot
people delivery people who are knocking
on the door how is this okay I don't
know police are going to be looking into
it and we do have to question ourselves
as a society when we get to the point
where someone ringing a doorbell
somebody who's lost or somebody who's
looking for help
can find themselves facing down the
barrel of a gun and a child it happened
to police who went to the wrong address
in a different state as well so
something's going on here no more and
more questions on this story and we will
stay on top of this for you